To me, the biggest story about I
this week
was not the president issuing
an executive order to curtail it
or the meeting on Capitol Hill
with Elon Musk and Mark Zuckerberg
trying to get a handle on it
or how it was utilized
to finish that new Beatles song.
Instead, it was the story
out of New Jersey
about how male students
at the Westfield High School were sharing
fake nude photographs
of their fellow female students doctored
from actual online pictures using A.I..
There are currently no federal laws
in the United States against the creation
of sharing non-consensual
deepfake pornography.
A recent study
found the number of pornographic
deepfakes online roughly
doubled every six months
from 2018 to 2020,
and that 96% of deepfakes
are sexually explicit and feature women
who didn't consent to the videos.
The incident in Westfield
took place over the summer, but officials
only learned about it on October 20.
The school implemented an investigation
and sent out an email
asking if a parent or guardian thinks
their child is a victim of a criminal act
related to the incident
to report it to the local police.
In a local Facebook group in Westfield,
some parents called to punish
whoever had created the images.
Others saw it as a forgivable,
youthful transgression.
In a statement
to CNN, the school
said, quote,
We are able to provide specific details
on the number of students involved
and any disciplinary actions
imposed as matters
involving students are confidential.
Joining me
now is one of those targeted
14 year
old Francesca Mani
and her mother, Dorota.
Francesca,
thank you so much for being here.
Sorry that this happened to you.
How did you learn of it?
I read the Wall Street
Journal Julie jargon piece,
and it said that
on a particular day in school,
the boys just started to act weird.
Yes.
So the day
before I found out they were no girl
knew was happening.
But we knew the boys knew something.
And the next day I was called down
to the principal's office
to be confirmed
as one of many students
of the air incident.
And I'm not going to lie.
After I left the office, I was crying.
I was walking the hallways.
I saw a group of boys
laughing at a group of girls
who were crying.
And that's when I realized
I shouldn't be sad. But I should be mad.
So I came home
and I told my mom
and I said,
We need to do something about this
because of this.
This is not fair to the
girls and this is not okay.
Francesca, correct me if I'm wrong.
I don't think you've seen the images.
Do you nevertheless know
how many girls were similarly victimized
and do you know who was responsible?
I know who was responsible.
And it has been rumored
that there are over
34 girls to be involved in this.
Mom.
Dorota, I'm
going to put something on the screen
from that Wall Street Journal piece,
and then I'll ask you for a reaction.
I'll read it out loud.
It says the following
Even among parents, there's no consensus.
In a local Facebook group.
Some called for harsh punishment
for whoever created the images.
Others deemed it a youthful transgression
that should be forgiven.
How do you see it? Dorota.
Listen.
I've heard over and over
that boys will be boys.
And I agree.
Boys will be boys.
Girls will be girls.
That being said, there's right and wrong.
There's legal and illegal
in this situation.
You know, they were some boys or a boy.
And that's to be determined who created
without the consent of the girls.
Inappropriate images.
At the same time when this transpired,
I'm speaking from Francesca of history.
There were multiple of boys
that reached out
to support her and say, listen, how can I
how can we help you?
This is not okay.
You know, we feel so bad.
What is there
for us to do to make it better?
You know? Many of them walk her home.
So, yes, boys will be boys,
but there's also right and wrong,
legal and illegal.
Francesca, do you think
that this should be best
dealt with by the school
or by local law enforcement?
The police?
I think it should be both.
I think the school should contribute
to helping this,
helping make all the girls
more comfortable in our school,
because so many girls
don't feel comfortable
knowing that he's walking our hallways.
And I also think there should be a law
and put it against the air to protect
everyone from this.
So, Francesca,
if you know who was responsible,
I presume that others in school know
this is the guy.
Has anything happened to him
as far as you know, so far?
Not really.
There is Not really, no.
Dorota, has there been any communication
among the parents?
Meaning of the girls victimized
and the parents or parent,
whatever the situation may be
of the young man
that you think was responsible for this?
Absolutely.
So multiple of mothers,
I think over 100 reached out to me.
I mean, only the ones who are outraged
in the way how Westfield High
conducted
the investigation
and how they treated this incident,
but also moms of previous incidents
that were just brushed off
and not taken seriously.
So I've listened nobody listened to them.
So I've listened.
I had no contact with the other side.
I know the name as per
what my daughter told me,
and principal of the school informed me
there was one boy.
Later on
we found out there
could be multiple of boys.
As per Westfield, the leader.
But none of those parents contacted us.
So Francesca, has the boy
apologize to you?
No, he has not.
Hmm.
What would you do if he did?
I don't.
I don't know. I think I would stay quiet.
And I don't think.
I just don't think it's right what he did
right.
Well, it's indefensible what he did.
Right? Yes.
You know, but I.
If I may add something,
I'm so proud of my daughter.
She's advocating for herself
and the other girls.
She's urging me to
make sure
there are other laws
in place for New Jersey.
So Senator Bramnick is behind our back
and making sure that whatever is right
now on the table
will be pushed this November,
making sure that New Jersey
children are safe.
She also wrote a letter
to President Biden
asking him to urge other governors
to make sure that there are laws in place
to protect our children.
So I think this issue is more complex
than just Westfield High School.
And this is our time and opportunity
to treat it as a
teachable platform
to shed the light of the
importance of this issue.
Francesca, good luck to you.
Thank you, Dorota.
Thank you.
Checking in on social media reaction.
Catherine,
what do we have from the world of ex
pornography?
Has done irrevocable damage
to developing young minds
and screwed up plenty of adults as well.
Yeah, it's just too prevalent.
I mean,
it used to have to be hard to find.
Right.
And now it's just.
It's the touch of a button.
I think it's also impacted
relationships
and expectations of young men because
it's so widely available
that they have an unrealistic.
Well, I said it.
Expectation of what life's all about.